this is for you
Islam that is establishing a Masjid and
a community center if you donate to
build this Masjid Allah will inshallah
build a house for you in Jannah with
bricks of gold and silver every person
who prays in this Masjid every child
that memorized the Quran you will
inshallah share in that reward donate
now guys and do not delay
[Music]
so guys we are here in Hyde Park and we
are going to go to people not like last
time asking them to keep an eye while
we're praying we're going to get them to
help me to do ablution which is wudu
let's see if we stop people
an awesome store would help me to do
will do would they do it and if they do
I'm going to step it up a notch I'm
going to wash my feet and let's see if
there's gonna be anyone that's going to
be actually helping me to do that and if
they do we've got an iPhone 11 and we've
got a little Samsung phone to give away
inshallah let's see who's going to help
us unless he's going to be patient
enough let's check it out
sorry sir I just wanted to ask a quick
question
sorry madam I don't need money I need to
pray can you just help me do evolution
I just need somebody to help me to wash
my face and hands and just oh please
sorry I need to pray I just need to wash
my face and my arms
what the hell
[Music]
sorry excuse me sorry to bother you guys
I need to pray
um I just need to do ablution can you
just help me just wash my face to pray I
need somebody to just help me wash my
face
sorry guys to bother you sorry I just
need to prove I need to do Evolution
because when can one of you guys help me
just do Evolution if it's okay
just basically I just need to wash my
face I'm up I need to go pretty I just
need somebody to hold the water I just
need to pray I need somebody to help me
do Evolution sorry man I need to pray I
need someone to just help me do
Evolution quickly man
yes
just just a little bit
yeah
I just need to wash my face and then my
feet and then I just need someone do you
want me to hold the water yes please and
I need to pray if we can just keep an
eye so nobody attacks let me get five
minutes oh I don't have my eyes
oh okay I'm ready sorry okay nice right
man I really appreciate it thank you
thank you thank you
sure I mean what do we need to do just
you just need to hold it I just need to
thank you I really appreciate it man
just because there's no one here I'm
gonna put my payments
where are you from uh Florida oh Florida
you guys you guys are holiday here yeah
okay interesting how are you guys here
okay sorry I know it's a bit weird
because well I can't breathe so I had no
one to hold the water so it was a bit
Yeah it won't take long just two minutes
you know
I need to wash my feet as well okay
yeah
sorry man
what's your name
okay you're a Christian
oh okay I appreciate man
yeah yes if you just come a bit here
yeah we're going to try to wash my mouth
and no just give me a bit more yeah
you guys do
somewhere else
[Music]
you don't get results yet
yeah I mean I'm not doing GCSE bomb
trying to trying to pass the test of
life to get me and just keep looking can
you help me yeah well thank you very
much I'm just gonna I just need to wash
my face and my feet and I'm just going
to pray three minutes is okay thank you
I really appreciate it thank you
wash my mouth and nose
face
thank you thank you
and my um thank you thank you very much
they are building a Masjid in Norway
just imagine for a second if you are the
one who donated towards this Masjid and
guess what every single person that does
will do that thousands if not millions
of people throughout many many years
imagine them praying Salah on that mat
you are going to get the reward of every
single one of them in your makayama
brothers and sisters press pause before
the amazing social experiment starts go
to the link and donate whatever you can
you study here
yeah okay
my
just a little bit yes
thank you very much thank you I really
appreciate it thank you you're very kind
way you guys
okay so just just one thing it's a
social experiment
um
I want to give you this
for helping me
yes it's a brand new airpods
I really appreciate it thank you well
you didn't have to do it
um
that's good you know some people be like
no you know I'm just like this okay
that's interesting what message would
you give to people you know if they are
somebody needed to help
yeah you more meaning yeah
Romania Chris Christian
uh yes okay that's fine why it's okay my
advice yeah be humble thank you
it's a social experiment there's a
camera there oh uh yeah I just want to
say uh thank you yeah we're giving out
60 pounds
okay you know what can I just destroy
the camera Come Close
um you could have not do it you know
some people are hostile what made you I
mean help me oh we're all people man
yeah yeah I appreciate it man are you
sure absolutely as a gift it's all good
no problem guys I really appreciate it
guys thank you very much my YouTube name
is Ali dawa
how old are you man
yeah it's good man appreciate give me
one second yeah
can you just hold on to this for one
second
you just hold on to that person
thanks man appreciate it
oh where'd you come from
Yo okay yo look at me oh
yeah
all right listen man yeah as you can see
listen listen
Manny we're talking sweet out bro I'm
always gonna run away after he's seeing
my feet you get me
[Laughter]
thank you
it'll take two minutes man I'm so sorry
to
you know spoil the fight I'm so sorry
yeah I just need someone to help me I'm
so sorry man I can just hold it are you
musliment oh is it okay so you know
about it yeah yeah okay Interesting Man
thank you
yeah
man of course thank you man anyway so
you guys just chilling here okay that's
good man you know what
you know what guys sorry guys this was a
social experiment just to see who would
help us there's a camera there
so just want to just want to say hello
and I want to appreciate thanks for the
help we're giving away 50 pounds nothing
much oh no no wow yeah oh he's happy
about it
do you want it we can donate it no
problem yeah let me give it to you guys
I appreciate it just gonna social
experiment to see who would help you
know but will you thank you very much
yeah yeah are you sure yeah no I'll take
it man you think you guys can
yeah if you want to stick to our word
have you got change
yeah man appreciate it man there we go
good transaction you help me do with it
thank you very much guys once again
sorry for disturbing you guys thank you
very much
[Music]
yeah thank you thank you thank you thank
you thank you very much thank you can
you just thank you can you just give me
three minutes I pray
thank you very much thank you what's
your what's your name
Matt
Karina my name Ali
really yes we do the social experiments
come okay this is iPhone 11 Apple brand
new this is for you which one you have
which one
[Music]
yeah okay all right sorry so guys you
know what happened look literally
yes yes
you know I like you you know what Auntie
let me tell you something I ask many
people nobody want to help you know what
happened she was not only that she was
washing my feet she was literally put
the water on my feet literally so God
bless you
I appreciate you as well thank you very
much thank you enjoy it and it's iPhone
11 yes Galaxy Samsung okay iPhone best
yes thank you very much
bye-bye guys
thank you take care thank you bye-bye
she was washing my face so much bro they
want to especially this way no no I want
your feet
so yeah
Galaxy
I don't know what are the old ones I
think yeah so it's really happy man well
it made me happy
Japan
sure yes yes please yes
who's that yes okay one thing yeah
thank you send me a picture
thank you take care bye-bye guys if you
want to see part two maybe with a little
give me some ideas I don't know the
whole point is to raise awareness
inshallah